Is it still possible for young people to
flourish in America? Big questions like this
usually make us think of top-down answers: "Kids
can't get ahead because capitalism is broken;"
"Marriages fail because the media is setting a bad
example." But psychologist Urie Bronfenbrenner's
theory of human development tells a different
story. He found that children grow and make
decisions within a layered system of relationships
and that those relationships with the closest
proximity to a child, like families, teachers,
and strong faith communities, have the greatest
influence. Other institutions are important but
distant. Government media and the larger society
matter less when the core is strong.
If we want to truly empower children,
we should partner with the people closest to them — giving
parents the power to choose great schools;
teaching kids that the family they form matters;
or helping young people recognize the value
of a personal faith commitment. Every single
effort helps set them up for future success.
To learn more about Urie Bronfenbrenner's
theory of human development, check out the
links in the description below. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.